la cuisine centrale de trappes fait peau
neuve
c'est ici que sont préparés les repas
des écoliers de la ville les marmitons
une cuisine pensé comme un véritable
outil pour apprendre à mieux manger on
voulons garder la maîtrise entière sur
la fabrication des menus pour les
enfants parce que nous avons développée
en parallèle le côté éducatif de
l'equilibre les moteurs en effet les
menus sont élaborés avec une
diététicienne qui forme également les
animateurs scolaire à cette
problématique
la ville de trappes a signé une charte
de l'association nationale des
restaurateurs de collectivités le
document élaboré en 1998 vise à faire
reconnaître la qualité de la
restauration publique territoriale la
qualité des produits de l'accueil et du
service en salle est prise en compte
mais aussi la bonne gestion du budget de
la cuisine si on avait fait une jolie
mentionné ceux des frais d'entretien de
maintenance importants et c'est aussi un
amortissement pendant qu'on n'arrivera
jamais à gérer prochaines initiatives de
la cuisine municipale les marmitons le
tri sélectif des déchets par les enfants
eux-mêmes et de recyclage des barquettes